roughly forty three thousand years ago a
young cave bear died in the rolling
hills on the northwest border of
modern-day Slovenia one thousand years
later a mammoth died in southern Germany
a few centuries after that the Griffon
vulture also died in the same vicinity
and we know almost nothing about how
these animals met their deaths but these
different creatures dispersed across
both time and space did share one
remarkable fate after their deaths a
bone from each of their skeletons was
crafted by human hands into a flute
think about that for a second imagine
you're a caveman 40,000 years ago you
mastered fire you built simple tools for
hunting you've learned how to craft
garments from animal skins to keep
yourself warm in the winter what would
you choose to invent next that seems
preposterous that you would invent the
flute a tool that created useless
vibrations and air molecules but that is
exactly what our ancestors did now this
turns out to be surprisingly common in
the history of innovation sometimes
people invent things because they want
to stay alive or feed their children or
conquer the village next door but just
as often new ideas come into the world
simply because they're fun
and here's the really strange thing many
of those playful but seemingly frivolous
inventions ended up sparking momentous
transformations in science in politics
and society take what may be the most
important invention of modern times
programmable computers now that the
standard story is that computers descend
from military technology
many of the early computers were
designed specifically to crack wartime
codes or calculate rocket trajectories
but in fact the origins of the modern
computer are much more playful even
musical than you might imagine
the idea behind the flute are just
pushing air through tubes to make a
sound was eventually modified to create
the first organ more than 2,000 years
ago someone came up with the brilliant
idea of triggering sounds by pressing
small levers with our fingers inventing
the first musical keyboard now keyboards
evolved from organs to clavichord to
harpsichords to the piano until the
middle of the 19th century when a bunch
of inventors finally hit on the idea of
using a keyboard to trigger not sounds
with letters in fact the very first
typewriter was originally called the
writing harpsichord flutes and music led
to even more powerful breakthroughs
about a thousand years ago at the height
of the islamic renaissance three
brothers in baghdad designed a device
that was an automated organ they called
it the instrument that plays itself
the instrument was basically a giant
music box the organ could be trained to
play various songs by using instructions
encoded by placing pins on a rotating
cylinder if you wanted the machine to
play a different song you just swapped a
new cylinder in with a different code on
it this instrument was the first of its
kind it was programmable now
conceptually this was a massive leap
forward the whole idea of hardware and
software becomes thinkable for the first
time with this invention and that
incredibly powerful concept didn't come
to us as an instrument of war or of
conquest or necessity at all it came
from the strange delight of watching a
machine play music in fact the idea of
programmable machines was exclusively
kept alive by music for about 700 years
in the 1700s music making machines
became the playthings of the Parisian
elite showman used the same coated
cylinders to control the physical
movements of what were called automata
an early kind of robot one of the most
famous of those robots was you guessed
it an automated flute player designed by
a brilliant French inventor named
Jacques de volcán song and as Vulcan SAW
was designing his robot musician he had
another idea if you could program a
machine to make pleasing sounds why not
program it to weave delightful patterns
of color out of cloth instead of using
the pins of the cylinder to represent
musical notes they would represent
threads with different colors if you
wanted a new pattern for your fabric you
just programmed a new cylinder this was
the first programmable loom
now the cylinders were too expensive and
time-consuming to make but a
half-century later another French
inventor named Jacques hard hit upon the
brilliant idea of using paper punched
cards instead of metal cylinders paper
turned out to be much cheaper and more
flexible as a way of programming the
device that punch card system inspired
Victorian inventor Charles Babbage to
create his analytical engines the first
true programmable computer ever designed
and punch cards were used by computer
programmers as late as the 1970s so ask
yourself this question what really made
the modern computer possible yes the
military involvement is an important
part of the story but inventing a
computer also required other building
blocks music boxes toy robot flute
players harpsichord keyboards colorful
patterns woven into fabric and that's
just a small part of the story there's a
long list of world-changing ideas and
technologies that came out of play
public museums rubber probability theory
the insurance business and many more
necessity isn't always the mother of
invention the playful state of mind is
fundamentally exploratory seeking out
new possibilities in the world around us
and that's seeking is why so many
experiences that started with simple
delight and amusement eventually led us
to profound breakthroughs now I think
this has implications for how we teach
kids in school and how we encourage
innovation in our work spaces but
thinking about play and the light this
way also helps us detect what's coming
next think about it if you were sitting
there in 1750 trying to figure out the
big changes coming to society in the
19th to 20th centuries automated
machines computers artificial
intelligence a programmable flute
entertaining the Parisian elite would
have been as powerful a clue as anything
else at the time
it seemed like an amusement at best not
useful in any serious way but it turned
out to be the beginning of a tech
revolution that would change the world
you'll find the future wherever people
are having the most fun